[Music]
in a basement below marioples as of
style steel plant Ukrainian border
guards sing the national anthem
they say they're defending the last
Bastion of Ukrainian territory in the
besieged port city
they're said to be 2 000 Ukrainian
Fighters Sheltering in the plant's vast
network of tunnels and bunkers as well
as a thousand civilians the focus of un
efforts to broker a humanitarian
corridor
the Ukrainian regiment known as the azov
Battalion released these pictures a
woman said to be a doctor tells of
increasingly dire conditions
guys are literally dying before our eyes
because we don't have any possibility to
evacue them there is no way to heal them
properly we just ask we beg to give us
at least slightest chance to save life
of these Fighters
above ground are the ruins of a city
that's been described as hell on Earth
mariopol has been pummeled into
submission a people facing what city
officials say is a catastrophic shortage
of drinking water and food
I had a beautiful house a good apartment
and now I have no apartment nothing
I live alone and no one can help me
I'm watching you
further north in Hakeem local Fighters
do what they can to protect their
neighbors
when your city is being destroyed when
your close people are being killed there
is no other option but to defend them
but they say they feel helpless against
Russia's fighting Power forced to stand
by as missiles Reign down
Russia's been intensifying its
operations in the East but Western
intelligence suggests moscow's troops
are only making minor advances that the
offensive is days behind schedule
the enemy is inflicting air missile and
artillery attacks on civilian and
Military infrastructure deep in
Ukrainian territory the regrouping and
strengthening of the occupying forces
continues
the U.S accuses Russia's President
Vladimir Putin of depravity and his
invasion but Russia's foreign minister
Sergey levrov says the West is at fault
and that NATO countries are doing
everything they can to prevent a
ceasefire by sending weapons to Ukraine
[Music]
until a deal is reached the fighting
rages on
Alexia O'Brien Al Jazeera